i watched a little bit of the breakfast
club interview and it seemed like snoop
kind of closed the deal he did he did
and i'm saying what does snoop say to
you
cause listen snoop dogg is in my opinion
um
the most famous rapper of all time i'm
talking about fame right my grandma
knows who snoop is your grandma knows
who snoop is my grandma don't know who
drake is but my grandma knows who the
[ __ ] snoop is you know what i'm saying
like
snoop is
that [ __ ] right let's just be
clear
so
did you probably pull up to the compound
in inglewood
yeah yeah i did that but i pulled up i
pulled up in uh
in manhattan somewhere he was at that
and he was in new york hell yeah wow we
kicked it he just revived i did that's
when i did the record with him on the
algorithm yeah yeah murder music record
and then we just we just linked and
exchanged numbers and we just kept
talking from there and he just put it in
perspective you know what i'm saying
because he just broke it down you know
what this business there's labels and
all that [ __ ] it just be real
corporate and all that he just like
let's call him
that type of [ __ ] you know snoop is a uh
a treasure man right right right what
i'm saying i love [ __ ] like that he's
good i'm gonna show you what i'm what
i'm about to do with this [ __ ] over here
i'm gonna show you i mean they better
put you in the new def jam vendetta
they got to i'm the [ __ ] butcher what
can you i think there's gonna be a new
they gotta make a new one they're crazy
if they don't but if they do you gotta
be in there with a [ __ ] with the
apron on bloody as [ __ ]
wow
wow buffed up [ __ ] they're gonna make
your sideburns extra crazy i mean you
have some crazy like bsf chains swinging
i mean crazy like the shits your
fatality will be a [ __ ] butcher now i
don't even think they had fatalities in
the first step jim vendetta i don't
think they did but we gonna eat some in
the new one but i'm ahead of [ __ ] like
i'm gonna have all the [ __ ] cleavers
just strapped up that should be crazy
now shout out to snoop